the amazing lights the biggest company
in LED gloving announced this week that
they are closing up shop they were
forced to be reckoned with in the
gloving world they appeared on Shark
Tank and yes even tried their hands at
the Led POI market so how do you go from
a 15 million dollar valuation to
shutting down
well I honestly don't have all of the
answers but I'll try to offer up some of
them here Drex here from drexfactor POI
sharing with you the love of poi
spinning and flow Arts to benefit your
body and brain and in this video we're
going to talk about the rise and fall of
one of the most dynamic and
controversial companies in the flow Arts
but before we dive in I just want to
give a quick shout out to the Friends of
the channel big thanks to dark monk fire
Mecca flow fests flow toys juggling
calling pyroterra light toys and Ultra
POI for helping to make the videos on
this channel possible you can learn more
about all of these amazing companies and
the work that they're doing to support
flow artists like yourself by checking
out the links that I have down in the
description of this video and special
thanks to the non-business Friends of
the channel Lane machinski and Becca
thank you so very much for supporting my
channel my work and my mission
on Monday January 9th EmazingLights made
an announcement via Instagram Facebook
and on their email list that rocked the
gloving world after more than a decade
of operations the company's website was
shutting down sales for remaining stock
were going to be done through sister
site I heart Raves but the message was
clear this was the end of the road
emazing lights was arguably the biggest
and most famous brand in the flow Arts
so it's shutting down is not a small
matter but how did it get so big and why
would it shut down that's a very very
big and complicated question but I'm
going to try and provide some answers
today I won't pretend that they will be
complete or even comprehensive but this
is how I see how we got here to start
with if we're going to talk about
amazing lights we really have to talk
about its CEO Brian Lim got started in
gloving and led props when he tried out
his first set of gloves back in 2010
believing himself to be a poor dancer
but surprised he could still draw a
crowd when using the gloves he saw the
potential for starting a business around
them and began selling sets out of his
trunk at a variety of of events in
Southern California before long he'd
quit his day job at Deloitte and was
selling Led gloves full time he opened
up a storefront selling the gloves and
hosting small competitions before
working up to a full e-commerce business
run out of a warehouse in Anaheim
California and emazing lights got big
really big not only were they pulling in
millions of dollars in Revenue every
year the company and Brian Lim himself
were getting written up in both the
local press as well as bigger
Publications like Inc magazine and
rolling stone and if you've heard of
either Brian Lim or emazing lights it's
pretty certain it's because of a certain
reality TV show called Shark Tank in
2015 Brian Lim appeared on the show and
wow judges Mark Cuban and Damon John
enough to get investment valuing his
company at 13 million dollars the last
valuation I saw for the company put its
market cap at 15 million for any company
in the flow Arts that is an incredible
feat but this meteoric success did not
come without controversy or adversity
one of the biggest shocks the company
faced came very near the beginning of it
when gloving was banned by the biggest
Rave event production company in the
country Insomniac events Raves and EDM
events were kind of the bread and butter
for the gloving community there was a
symbiotic relationship between the music
and culture around them and gloving
itself so this was a a pretty huge blow
why the ban officially two reasons were
given one that I think is kind of
ridiculous and one that I actually don't
the first is that event promoters
believe there was a relationship between
gloving and illicit drug use whether it
was people tripping out as Glovers
perform for them or people smuggling
drugs into events in their gloves
themselves promoters single gloving out
as having unique associations in this
matter and banned it from their events
which I have to say in terms of
associations with drug culture at a rave
it's a rave I honestly think it's kind
of weird to make loving a scapegoat here
the second actually does kind of make
sense to me though the reasoning goes
something like this from what I've seen
most loving light shows happen with both
the performer and the person they're
performing for sitting down I've heard
of a lot of people mention them being
associated with cuddle puddles and the
like and on the surface of it there's
nothing wrong with that all performance
arts have their specific contexts and
manner in which they are performed
but when you've got a dozen people down
on the floor during an event that has
hundreds or even thousands of attendees
it can create problems for crowd flow or
Worse become a hazard if there's a
stampede or a fire I've been in a crowd
Stampede before and I can tell you
without a doubt that if anybody had been
sitting either in the middle or edge of
that crowd they would have gotten badly
heard and likely would have caused a lot
of other injuries to people tripping
over them and getting trampled as well
don't get me wrong it sucks but it also
does make sense from the perspective of
an event producer while that was an
event that had a negative impact on the
entire industry there were also events
that more specifically made emazing
lights a controversial company within it
in 2015 a former employee started up a
Kickstarter campaign to fund development
of an open source microlight or osm chip
to make available to anyone who wanted
to reprogram it the kickstarter was a
success but Discord soon followed as
EmazingLights claimed that the employee
had stolen trade secrets from them and
worse the open source chip ran afoul of
a patent that they owned the subsequent
lawsuit not only created sharp Division
and conflicts in the gloving community
it also pulled in several other LED
glove retailers who were selling the
osms into the crossfire of this
situation as well now I am not a patent
attorney electric engineer or software
engineer so I am in no position to
comment on the validity of the claim but
I can tell you that in the end the
former employee settled and it left deep
divisions in the gloving community that
remain even to this day and probably the
example that's most relevant to my
audience would have to do with the
company's pivots into other flow Arts
while the company's forays into
developing orbits was relatively
uncontroversial the same cannot be said
of its attempts to develop its own set
of LED POI the company sought to bring
more types of flow artists into its fold
by developing its own set of LED POI and
putting a colorful marketing campaign
behind them
only it didn't quite go as planned when
emazing lights first released its e-poi
in 2016 people couldn't help but notice
that the POI looked really really
similar to pod POI from flow toys from
the form factor to the design of the bag
that they came in to add to that the
company created a colorful marketing
video that took footage from many
prominent POI Spinners without asking
their permission it really did not look
good for the company a lot of flow Arts
culture has countercultural routes and
as such there's kind of a distrust both
for Authority as well as anything deemed
corporate or for-profit lots of
companies in the flow Arts have to
thread a pretty delicate needle of
working towards success while at the
same time appearing humble and Community
Driven emazing lights sure looked a lot
like the faceless corporate overlords
that flow artists harbored no shortage
of anxieties around and honestly on this
point I do actually have some sympathy
for the company they made some pretty
big mistakes but I can also understand
why they made them thing is in gloving
you're dealing with lights inside of
gloves the there's not a whole lot of
room to create distinctive form factors
the bulk of the Innovation and
intellectual property goes into the
chips themselves and how they're
programmed so when that's the world
you're coming from and you're working to
develop a set of poi I can absolutely
see how you'd come at it by creating a
really similar form factor and then
focusing your attentions on the
programming for the chips and lights
inside of that form factor bear in mind
this is me giving the benefit of the
doubt I have no idea what the process
looked like on the inside either way
they might have stepped into something
that they might not have known was going
to be a sensitive issue can I see a way
that that could have been done without
malice yes if my charitable
interpretation is right though should
they still have done their homework
better and been more aware of how these
practices would be received outside of
the gloving world also yes so clearly
over the course of the past decade the
company has been navigating some ups and
downs but what ultimately caused them to
close up shop did their reputation take
one hit too many and they couldn't
recover from it
honestly no I don't think so if there's
one thing that's been made clear in the
wake of the announcement it's that this
company meant quite a lot to a lot of
people even people who had been
outspoken critics of the company clearly
respected it on some level with one
commenter comparing emazing lights to
the Nike of the gloving world so did the
controversies sink the ship here no they
clearly still had no shortage of
Community Support so what did well I am
no expert and I have never worked for
the company but from where I'm sitting
there are three key issues that I think
are important to put into the
conversation the first we already looked
at a bit it's mentioned in the farewell
message as well as something I noted
earlier in this video the gloving ban at
Raves had a cataclysmic effect on the
gloving market and the growth of the
community in general again I think that
there's a symbiotic relationship between
gloving and the Rave scene and gloving
really wasn't a part of what I think was
the biggest boom in EDM events as a
business with Raves as a key way to
expose new people and onboard them and
to the art it was always going to be
hard to pull in Nuke lovers through
other means that didn't stop them from
trying though e-nazing lights did pivot
into hosting and sponsoring competitions
founding the international gloving
competition or igc in 2011 the year
after gloving was banned I actually went
to one of these events myself and I'll
confess that it was actually a cool and
unique Vibe dozens if not hundreds of
Glovers and orbiters sharing and
competing over the course of two days in
an Esports arena in Anaheim and the year
after I went they pivoted into doing the
event completely online
I can't help but think that was a sign
that perhaps they weren't getting as
much engagement through the competitions
as they'd hoped for and were switching
to a model that had less overhead costs
in other words competitions as a
replacement for participation in EDM
events in the end might not have had the
impact that they were hoping for second
we have to talk about covid I think
it'll be years before we're fully aware
of just how huge an impact the covid-19
pandemic had on a variety of different
businesses but one thing that I can tell
you for sure is that it had a
catastrophic impact on two things that I
think were really important to emazing
lights Live Events and Chip Supply
chains the lack of Live Events was a
factor cited by the company itself in
its statement it's hard to bring new
people into the gloving world if they're
not being exposed to it and it can be
hard to do that without competitions and
smaller events in which people might
seek loving for the first time but that
wasn't the only industry impacted by the
pandemic Supply chains have been
absolutely devastating dated for the
past two years and one of the biggest
shortages worldwide is in computer chips
and integrated circuits I know of
several other flow Arts companies that
have been set back and releasing new
products or even being able to keep old
ones in stock as a result of the shocks
I had a hunch that this was a
contributing factor to the shutdown so I
actually wrote an email to amazing light
CEO Brian Lim and he confirmed for me
that it indeed had been a challenge for
the company okay so what's the final
factor in emazing light shutting down
well honestly it's that I think a lot of
us are actually looking at this in the
wrong way so I'll confess that I was a
little surprised by the announcement but
not all that surprised here's why
purely coincidentally I got on the
emazing Lights website a few months ago
and I noticed something that I thought
was really peculiar most of the product
listings on the site were gone this is a
website that once hosted not just
emazing lights products but also
products from several other companies as
well but this was not true of their
sister sites amid the rapid growth of
the amazing lights the company expanded
into Rave apparel as a business growing
into the amazing group with I heart
Raves and the acquisition of into the am
the websites for each of these Brands
appear to be alive and well and it
appears the remaining products for
emazing lights are actually going to be
moved to I heart Raves they'll also
still be available on Amazon but that's
not relevant to where I'm going with
this gloving is banned at Raves and has
limited reach outside of them
you know it isn't Bandit Raves and still
has a massive reach
clothes pivoting into apparel was always
a good move because it meant staying
within a demographic the company already
understood but without having to work
around the restrictions that gloving was
facing the barrier to entry is
incredibly low and even non-ravers will
sometimes buy the colorful clothes
associated with it they got into selling
not just LED props but a whole lifestyle
around it and those Brands aren't going
anywhere I don't think we should be
looking at this as a 15 million dollar
company that collapsed but as a company
that's likely still healthy merely
shutting down its riskiest and least
profitable division to focus on the
parts of the business that are working
it takes a lot of research and testing
to launch new electronics products it's
tough and it takes a lot of time and
effort and in some cases it's also just
not worth it I know it's kind of a
better pill to swallow but in the end it
may just be that while gloving was what
got the business started It ultimately
wasn't what was going to keep it going
or at least not at the level of the
people running it we're looking for but
like just on a personal note I do think
it's important to Mark events like this
regardless of how you feel about emazing
lights and its products or the people
who run it this is a company that was
featured in the national press and on
television it's a company that people
outside of the flow Arts were not
unlikely to have heard of having a
company like that out in the world that
can expose more people to what we do and
shows that there's a massive amount of
value in it I think is a good thing I am
a little sad to see the company go and I
hope for the best for the people who
work there and I also hope that other
companies that either exist now or in
the future continue to raise the profile
of the flow Arts because what we do is
cool and I think more people ought to
know about it
but for today
R.I.P emazing lights and thanks for all
the times
good and bad so what do you think why
did emazing lights ultimately shut down
I did a lot of research for this video
and honestly most of it didn't make it
end there are things that I missed
deliberately in order to keep the scope
of this video more focused and there are
likely things that I never knew about
sound off in the comments and tell me
why do you think the amazing lights shut
down did you get anything out of this
video please leave me a like comment
share and subscribe to keep the
conversation going to help other people
find it and to help my channel grow this
video would not be possible if not for
the wonderful support of all of these
amazing people right here these are my
flow patrons over on patreon and they
along with the people listed down in the
description helps make this video and
all the videos on my channel possible
thank you one and all for your very
generous support do you like my videos
do you like my flow sessions Vlogs
reviews Combos and more I I'm on a
mission to bring POI spinning and flow
Arts to The Wider world and help people
connect with their brains and their
bodies so help me do it head on over to
patreon.com
drexfactorpoi and sign up you can do
that at the link in the description or
the card that just popped up if you are
watching on YouTube there you can get
access to a whole host of awesome
rewards and help me along in my mission
do check that out please and thank you
this is not the first time I've done a
video charting the rise and fall of a
company in the flow Arts to check out
some of my other videos on Flow Arts
economics and culture I will leave a
link to a playlist of videos on that
topic down in the description as well as
up on screen if you are watching on
YouTube thanks so much for watching and
make sure to get outside and flow today
I'll see you with a brand new video real
soon
peace